Let's get to making ears. Making ears — a very, very important manoeuvre.
We can fold surface in on the right and left. First of all, little-ears.
With ears in and accelerator we achieve sink rates of 3 to a maximum of 3.7 metres per second sink.
But we're flying straight ahead doing it. That means we still have forward flight and so can, for instance, escape from any area we want to get out of.
So very effective, very good and very simple. That's why I like it.
By making ears — you can remember this — anything that collapses first of all brakes the wing.
If we look at it from the side, by making ears we've now reduced surface.
We brake the wing a bit on the outer wings on the right and left.
That is, our angle of attack increases now.
Now that's a bit bad for us, because with the increased angle of attack we've of course become slower.
Through the smaller surface we have an increased wing loading.
Because our weight has stayed the same.
That means the weight per square metre of surface is significantly greater than before.
That means we now have a bit more surface.
It also means that the stall point — the point where we prevent the wing from flying forward — has also shifted upward.
So it's become higher.
I'm just making an example, it doesn't match reality, but just so you can follow the whole thing a bit.
With open wing we're at a stall point of 18 to 20 km/h.
With ears in and higher wing loading we're at 24, 23 to 25 km/h.
And at this surface we're in the wing loading area.
But we've now become slower due to the increased angle of attack.
That means our window — which was so big to the stall point before — has now become smaller.
So the stall is much more easily possible.
On top of that it's often the case that you want to pump the ears a bit more, and the stall is simply present much faster.
That combined with thermals, for example, would then be fatal.
For that reason, in our training making ears always only in combination with the accelerator.
Because by accelerating I tilt the canopy further forward and down — I reduce
the angle of attack, I even increase the sink rate again, and I'm
now with my, or my stall window, that's now become somewhat bigger again.
So I have more distance to the stall point again. And that's why with us making ears is always
only in combination with the accelerator. Good, how do we do the whole thing? Making ears,
actually very simple, we keep the brake at the loop in the hand, we set ourselves up on the accelerator,
whoever doesn't get into the accelerator easily can also take the brake in one hand
and then set up the accelerator. Then the brakes go back into the respective
hand. Then we should push the accelerator, so that with both legs we nicely stand
symmetrically lightly in it, 30 to 40 percent. Now we try to orient ourselves,
we look for the outermost A-line. It runs on the A riser group simply far outward
to the wing, but doesn't go to the wingtip of the wing. That would be the stabilo line and
that's mostly found on the B riser group. Here in my case it also has a different
colour than the remaining lines on the B riser group. Sometimes though, in terms of colour, the manufacturer
hasn't chosen very cleverly. We've also had it where the outermost stabilo line
had a colour matching — that is, identical to — the A riser group. So on the A riser group all
the lines were red and the stabilo line on the B riser group was also red. So not very cleverly chosen.
That's why try to really orient yourselves, it has to be the outermost A-line. That's
always hung individually on A-rated wings. Look, you see it, one line hangs
alone on one line-lock and one line hangs alone on a wing wing wing wing wing.
And is even led alone on a riser. This is often even marked
with a small flag or a different colour. So that should also make the whole thing a bit
easier for you, to find this line. Then, to grab this line and fold the surface up
there, you have to hold it so that you take the thumb and the index finger above
this line-lock.
And now it's important, to take it firmly.
Count in your head, we want to pull symmetrically, that is count in your head, 21, 22, bam, at
23 I pull the line down. And now, so the line doesn't uncontrollably
snap back up on me, we hold it at the main riser, where we then are. And once we have that
and we look up and see, ah yes, we've made the ears cleanly,
then we give full bar, that is push the accelerator all the way through.
Now we can
steer, only with weight shift. And with harnesses with a seat board that works very,
very well. With harnesses without a seat board we can, if that's not enough — the weight shift —
we can by pulling on the inner riser, that is really pulling on it and leaning the weight
onto it, we can get the wing around the corner even better.
To exit we simply go into a neutral position, ease back a little out of the bar,
simply not too much, max 50 percent, then let the A-lines first symmetrically
up. If the ears are now still in — that's why it's important to look at the wing —
if the ears are still in, then we leave the accelerator in and pump
powerfully once. Remember the wing loading, that's why keep the accelerator in. Then
pump once, if the ears are out we can come out of the bar, if the ears still
stay in, then count in your head, 21, 22 and only two to three seconds later comes
another powerful pump. Then we come out. Good, that's it for making ears.